mayor of greater manchester andy burnham
joining us now hello to you mr mayor
you're procrastinating
allowed the virus to spread in your
region
well uh i'm not sure it's helpful to go
over the coals we should be facing
forward at the moment but
it's not true either okay if you go back
to those negotiations with the
government
we were left waiting over a whole
weekend myself and the ten leaders of
greater manchester well the government
walked away
so they need to get their facts right
but also we wouldn't have been in that
position
had the government listened to sage back
in september
uh and brought forward the national
circuit break much earlier so
as i said i don't know how the
government thinks it's helpful
to do this and i also don't know why
they think imposing tears on the whole
of the country is
is an appropriate response just because
they had a row with me it doesn't sound
like very grown up government to me
i do want to talk about that but i do
just want to pick up if i may in a
little bit more detail on what the uh
transport secretary
was saying you know he he was speaking
on behalf of the government this morning
and he basically in a thinly veiled
attack on you personally
basically said that if you had come to
the table
and done what the government had said
earlier then uh
more lives could have been saved you've
cost lives by your action in other words
well as i said a moment before kay i was
at the table and at the start of the
whole tears process i said to the
government
let's get this right together so that we
can reset things national local
government together that's just a fact
that i did that
and i never kind of sought the situation
that developed
but your question actually sort of
answers
you answer your own question said if you
do what the government wants to do
so let me remind people of the matter of
principle that i took a stand on the
government wanted to lock down
businesses
in greater manchester but only pay
people in those businesses 67
of their wages and let's remember they
were people working in pubs in
bookmakers in bingo halls i said that
wasn't right
when office workers had been given
four-fifths of their wages earlier in
the year
and also they were offering no support
whatsoever
to people who are self-employed and on
both of those fronts i said you cannot
take away
people's livelihoods and not help them
manage in this situation it was a point
of principle okay
i took a stand i'm glad i did i would do
it again
of course the government has since
conceded on those points
and there is now a proper furlough
scheme back in place and the support for
people who are self-employed
it just seems to me that you know they
can't leave it alone now they want to
they want to come back at it and they
want to to punish me and blame me for
for everything can't we just agree that
there was a difference of opinion it was
resolved
and now we all must look forward to
getting things right going forward
that's that's the right way for everyone
to to go about things
but it's almost a bit of divide and
conquer isn't it because
not only um did that we have that veiled
attack on you we also heard how well
liverpool had done
um during uh movement into tier three
um in addition to that we're being told
that regional mayors will have no
influence whatsoever on what's going to
happen on thursday when we find out
which tier system
we're in i wonder if you have a view on
both of those points
well you're right on the um divide and
rule points it's clearly what they're
doing isn't it and everyone can see what
they're doing
certainly here in the northwest uh in
liverpool they
they can read between those lines uh no
problem at all and everyone can see the
the government's tactics there but more
broadly you know why are they punishing
everybody because they had a route with
us
but but as i said it was a row that
needed to be had because we
helped win a better support package for
very low paid workers and people who are
self-employed and i'm glad we did take
that
that stand but it doesn't say much about
the government that the minute their
challenge k they just then have to say
oh well
i'm sorry but i can't work with anybody
we're just going to sort of bulldoze our
way
our way through you know that that isn't
the way to go about things and actually
if you talk to steve brotherham
and you talk to people in lancashire and
talk to people in sheffield
they felt first time round uh things
were railroaded through and there wasn't
a real negotiation or a real discussion
so i'm not sure they've changed
at all to be honest but there is a
danger here
they're gonna get a reputation if
they're not careful of being quite a
bullying government if they don't get
their own way
they take their their toys home their
ball home and then they just try and
impose their will
that i don't think is is a responsible
way to govern there are going to be
disagreements they created
these positions that that i hold you
know there's no point in having
devolution
if you just sort of you know you you
kind of bow down and you just do as
you're told all the time governments get
things wrong
and sometimes governments need to be
challenged and i won't be able to look
my residence here in great manchester in
the eye
if i sold them down the river just
because the government told me that's
what they were
going to do so whitehall and westminster
needs to
needs to sort of decide here they need
to grow up do they want evolution or do
they not
because sometimes devolution is needed
to be a check and balance in the system
to stop governments bulldozing their
will on the people because as we all
know it's the north of england
that have been at the sharp end of
government's behaviors over many many
years
we are finding our voice now we are not
going to be
pushed around in the way that we were in
the past
and if the government doesn't like that
and whitehall doesn't like that well i'm
sorry but they're going to have to get
used to it
um is there anything that you can do
though um going forward because you know
the government has said they're not
going to negotiate with you or any other
regional leader
they're going to put these tears in
place and they're going to tell us what
they are on thursday so yabu sucks to
you
[Music]
well if that's what they're going to do
it's what they're going to do okay
they're they're
they're the governments i've been saying
to them all the way through work with us
you know we'll probably help you
by giving you more intelligence from
what it feels like on the ground you
know that's what we've been saying to
them all the way
at the beginning we said look localize
test and trace rather than centralize it
it probably would have worked better and
you'd have got
more value of that 22 billion pounds
that you were you were asking the
transport secretary
about and that offer remains work with
us we're still in a national
crisis discuss with us how we're going
to make these things work
you know there's a mass testing offer on
the table that's a positive thing i want
to talk to them
about that we've got to learn to draw a
line under things there will be
disagreements
let's have those disagreements resolve
them draw a line and then
move forward that's the responsible way
for people to go out
to go about things i respect their
position as the elected government
but i hope they respect mine elected by
2.8 million people here in greater
manchester
we've got a legitimate voice to put back
to the government and if they don't
listen to it of course it will get
louder and we will stand our ground
but i would still want to work with them
and i've said
passed a message through to the prime
minister i would be pleased to welcome
him to manchester at any time
to discuss how we can clear the air move
things forward on a better footing and
that offer still stands
what does standing new ground look like
it looks like what we did um you know if
i
knew that again that low paid workers
were going to be pushed
into real punishing hardship i would
take a stand for them i would always
do that and i'm glad we did it because
it wasn't right was it
was it right to say that they were only
worth two-thirds of their wages
while other people are worth four fifths
now that's the bottom line isn't it
people
the government say that i was
showboating or i was political posturing
no i wasn't there was a point of
principle involved and i always act but
there's principle
involved it's like with the three
million excluded at the moment okay
there's a point of principle involved
there too
how can you give some people eighty
percent of their income
but leave three million people out in
the cold with absolutely nothing
that's the point of principle that's why
i'm taking a stand on that but it's also
why i took a stand
over over people's wages if it's pure
politics well people will make their own
judgments about that and then
they will rightly conclude that that is
showboating but i
act where there was a point of principle
that is what standing your ground
looks like i've learned to do that over
the years on the various issues that
i've worked on from hillsborough to a
whole range of other issues
you know i came to a point in politics
where i wasn't prepared to go along with
the
the ways of westminster anymore the way
they like to to do things
somebody needs to stand up to them and
whether where they affect the lives of
people in greater manchester
particularly the lowest paid
i will always stand my ground
finally with the respect mr mayor that
you know you
are looking after the people of greater
manchester the prime minister has got to
look after the united kingdom he's got
enough on his plate dealing with
the devolved nations without pesky
politicians
in the regions giving him grief as well
when he's trying to save as many lives
as possible
well that would be a fair criticism if
we hadn't offered
all year to him to help and i promise
you
it was all year what can we do involve
us more let us take more of the strain
with test and trace k
and i can't remember how many times i
came on your program
saying that that we were prepared to
take more responsibility for these
things to help him
and the government so they didn't listen
they didn't listen
all year and they kept centralizing uh
everything so
you know there's only so many times you
you can offer but but as i say
the office still stands you know i'm
somebody who cares about this country
cares about the people of this country i
always want to do the best buy them as
far as i
see it and going back to what i did in
october i
passionately believe that that was the
right stand to take and
actually it's led to better protection
now as people go back into
into tier three on thursday so i don't
regret it
if the government can't handle that well
punish me
but why punish every other local
authority in the country by just cutting
them out of the discussion
that doesn't sound to me like very
responsible grown-up government and i
think this government needs to
to kind of mature a little now in its
approach it's been in for a year
it takes a while for a government to
find its fee but i think they need to
find a better way of working with people
involve more people respect the role of
local
and regional government